hello I'm a Nostalgia Critic I remember
it so you don't have to before I start
this review let me tell you a little
story about a guy named Mako and why you
don't want to mess with him
Mako apparently was a very popular sort
of underground voice celebrity he did
voices for Avatar The Last Airbender
which I never heard of Samurai Jack
which I never saw and played a cure of
the wizard and Conan which I barely
remember so as you can tell I barely
know who this guy is but apparently a
lot of you do and we're not very happy
when I made fun at this voice in the
TMNT movie I remember it like it was
yesterday okay maybe I don't remember
like it was yesterday but I have a clip
his home has become like an empty shell
each of your brothers okay what did they
do this players voice it sounds like mr.
Miyagi if he smoked a million marbles
marbles well apparently a lot of you
took this the wrong way thinking those
making fun of the actor himself sending
me emails like you don't mess with Mako
motherfucker
leave Mako alone he is the man and you
should crucify your privates for making
fun of Mako crap that goes with one-year
anniversary surprise the fact is I don't
hate Mako I don't know make oh I know
nothing about Mako I just thought the
voice was a little different compared to
the other Splinter said for it before
I mean sheesh yeah it's like the guy
died or something damn it okay okay so
just to recap I don't hate Mako I don't
know Mako so logically I can't hate
someone
I don't know especially when he's dead
that makes it very difficult so no
disrespect I apologize let's move on but
how about helming a segue out of that oh
wait a minute
Mako was in Conan Conan starred Arnold
Schwarzenegger Arnold Schwarzenegger was
in a horrible Conan ripoff which was
known as Red Sonja
just when you thought barbarian
role-playing was restricted to the
bedroom red Sonia dares to show us that
half-naked people and loin cloths is not
only fashionable by highly
cost-effective a shame it doesn't have a
well-developed Orie to go along with it
this is another one of those classic bad
movies that everyone seemed to talk
about but why is it really so bad that
even deserves mentioning well grab a
poacher pretentiousness and let's find
that so it starts out with the young
sonya being played by Brigitte Nielsen
as we see her lying unconscious with her
house on fire but then she wakes up to
find a mystical unfinished special
effect who tells her about her woes you
are suffering Sonya fairy godmother at
vengeance shall be yours
whoa fairy godmother who kicks ass
vengeance on queen gedren who wanted you
for herself
your disgust was clear and so it was
that Garen ordered your family murdered
your body violated by her soldier I'm
the only one that finds a weird that a
woman is explaining what happened to the
person that it just happened to I mean
she just went through all this why'd she
have to be reminded queen gedren wanted
you for herself yeah I know this all
happened like a minute ago your disgust
was clear yeah I know all of this
Chadron ordered George
nerds bill kind of a painful memory
really your body violated by her soldier
oh thanks for bringing that up but in
your quest for justice and vengeance
you will need great strength well so
we're not gonna get it from this pack
talk so I'm not kidding the mystical
fairy waves her magic wand so that Sonia
can possess a great amount of strength
and maybe just maybe turn into a real
boy so if you're like me you're probably
wondering who the hell was this spirit
where did you come from why does she
want help Sonia out so bad like most bad
movies they decide not to tell us so
really you could put anything there and
it would make just about as much sense
you can put Ronald McDonald in that
position and be just as logically
satisfying try once more just for me and
me battle me so we cut two years in the
future as we see the ancient order of
silly hands is planning to do away with
an evil power that mankind cannot
control where is the Lord of Eternia he
has not come - he should be here for the
destruction of the talisman but we
cannot delay we will proceed without him
and take those ridiculous things off so
we see the priestesses as they plan to
get rid of the evil talisman which seems
to be shaped like a radioactive booger
but canceled anthrax is under attack as
the evil queen gedren surrounds the
castle with our soldiers o god of gods
it has become too powerful for us and we
must destroy it before it destroys the
world
I assure absolutely nothing will stop
this ceremony so let me just proceed as
slowly as possible
showing how confident I am that we are
about to destroy this evil power in fact
I feel like it's called already remember
that evil power that was so long it shit
takes
so the soldiers enter the castle killing
off all the priestesses protecting the
glowing sour skill but Garen wants to be
sure she has the right mystical power of
doom
so she test it out touch it my god a
chunk of people out of existence
touch it
no touch it so it is true only women may
touch it take it out you know I'm very
uncomfortable with these choices of
words only women may touch it take it
out
she wants her for herself if I just
heard the audio to this I swear I was
listening to a medieval porn ah by the
way does this guy in the picket fence
hand look familiar to you
that's right it's the Gestapo guy from
Raiders of the Lost Ark and yes he
always has that face indicate to think
he was just born with its wagon it's
like that can't be created so anyway one
of the women runs away as the soldiers
chase her down but she's only approached
by gasps ooh but they cook it down but
unfortunately the soldiers shoot the
woman in the back is Arnold catches her
okay you can tone down the music guys
he's just carrying her it's not very
exciting you can bring your meat back
now it's a fight sing hello
let's just see what she run has to say
must destroy the talisman
we must find my sister
take me I know where she is
please sorry I totally blanked what was
that
so Arnall is told to find Red Sonja who
lives in the training grounds of what
the hell is that you have nothing more
to learn Red Sonja I don't know you
watch dedications I shall be your
Gandalf for the evening you must learn
to like men a little better
come on how could you take him seriously
without snickering but in life all is
that swordplay yeah
hatred of men in a lovely young woman
okay it could be our downfall are you
going
that would have been music to my ears
thirty years ago sorry sorry keep going
quick his waistband he's making Queen
Amidala club look subtle I know
so Messer overkill tell Sonia that she
can take one weapon as a kid for being
such a good student and it turns out one
sword seems to be calling her name
literally
Oh a singing sword is the ancient
mythology of Bugs Bunny cartoons
so Arnold approaches the training
grounds through the mystical God taking
a dump
as he informs red Sonia that her sister
is dying and that she only has moments
to speak to her you must destroy the
talisman Sonia sent it into darkness
swear that you will I swear
is dead
Thank You captain obvious like a hit by
an arrow you'll be sure to tell me right
so Sonya decides to set out and destroy
the evil talisman which apparently is
very easy to locate someone is using the
tenesmus
no I think wily coyote store machine
just backfired again
I know tries to come along with Sonya
but she declares that she needs no land
to help her out it's no business of
yours and I'll a my you may be wrong on
both counts I know you appraise the girl
but dangerous men trade then I'll learn
it by myself God why do these people try
to act as I try to watch a new person
trying to teach another Mew person how
to talk we then come across a young
print you may also recognize from
another movie I refused to surrender
once a dude's that's right it's the star
of surf ninjas Wow
I'm really amazed at how an amazing
these cameos are quickly come come to me
no slippery do you want me to fall in
that boiling mud don't worry just take
the advice that you gave in your other
movie remember bend your knees you
you're so turns out the prince is a
spoiled brat of a destroyed Kingdom
who's always followed by his helper
named Falcon
what's the princes name you may ask His
Royal Highness the prince tarn Prince
tard that's not very PC is it
Sonya question is the prince to find out
who destroyed his kingdom what happened
what happened queen gedren attacked us
what happened
get Rijn queen gedren i'm acting so she
continues on her quest as the Prince
decides to take a walk he comes across a
group of warriors who get pretty upset
when their leader doesn't let her pass
and she
dancing in the chest that's usually not
a good icebreaker but Arnold is there to
help her out get away get away go what
about you I can hold them ah help me I
cannot hold them meanwhile we cut to the
evil fortress of queen gedren
where we see her get ready to set up the
talisman and use its awesome power for
the forces of evil like candles much
enemies are approaching the outer Empire
okay ah walking still walking and
training room rented out from Castle
Grayskull wow I'm so glad they showed us
the long walk to the throne
otherwise I never was figuring out how
the hell she got there I'm just a zoom
it was magic so she calls upon her
sorcerer who I swear it whiz Oh from the
bozo show who asked him to show her the
enemies that are coming her way
boy I never seen a poor excuse to have
new to be in the film outside hope or no
I mean what the hell was that were they
really so desperate for a pity shot that
they had to just throw it randomly into
the middle of the movie are there just
no adult theaters in this fantasy world
that girl in July send out a small
ambush buddy no we'll wait till they get
a little closer it makes me seem stupid
or that way so Sonia finally gets to the
boundaries of the evil world Wow subtle
it's like home and gardens outside of
Mordor berkov in the land of Perpetual
night fog play my arrival Oh keep quiet
come on that Prince of cards is a better
actor than you and he's only like five
so they cross the bones of a giant
decomposing rhino whatever
as Tony tries to teach the young prince
of lesson in manners
I was disarmed by those ruffians the
other day I noticed so it needn't be
faithful I understand kill me come on
please do what well simple isn't it but
it's not in the rule book
you see fencing and fighting are two
different things as well as acting and
looking pretty after the prince finally
asked nicely Sonia agrees to teach him
in the art of self-defense
you were disarmed because you hold the
hill too tight Rick gently see gently I
see
like this your highness Slim's fast so
we move on to the next level thymine
location where they discovered our
monster that's looking in the water oh
god is that fake come on I've seen
better effects from the act of poison
the Popeye movie that's hopeless bleak
against this mechanical side of it we
get a visit from an old familiar face
hello
I'm stealing this movie Suvarna jumps
into the water and tries to save the day
okay I think we spent way too much time
watching Arnold ride this thing I don't
even think he's really fighting it I
think it's just enjoying the ride I
can't kill it at the machine oh yeah
because they always have robotic
mechanical machines in barbaric times
where they get that thing bang the old
RadioShack Sonia we have to bind it down
the chance yes because as we all know
robots see out of their eyes what sense
does that make
does it also scream like a banshee if
you mailed in the mechanical groin of me
why build it that way so they skip the
monster and continue on their quest but
Arnold Sword is extending for Sonia as
we partake in a love scene which I like
to call love and the dueling accents no
man may have me unless he has beaten me
in a fair fight so the only man that can
have you is one who's tried to kill you
that's logic hey Arnold's pointing out
the Platteville's
don't be a fool I don't want to kill you
besides my heart will always belong to
flavor play so they fight I guess as
well as couple do as the little prince
observes the commotion what the hell did
I miss I will eat you child tonight I
dine on Chinese ah ha ha ha yeah
apparently Arnold is so strong he needs
a string to hold the child up either
that or he's just been a puppet the
whole time either one one surprised me
maybe the kids choreography is better
than those two they showed me that will
be about back it squeak so they both tie
rouse laying next to a tree and get
transfer me what what happened did I
just give up what did they make Whoopie
afterwards are they a couple down under
they still hate each other ok
screw it so they get to the Evo 4 just
where apparently the evil talisman is
held they told me a model they quickly
had to decide who will stand guard
outside in case any of them are spotted
who stand guard this doorway the post of
danger Falcon me here
I don't know what's coming out that door
no no I'm going up I'll take my chances
in there and I have to go in
is urea dark get a fucking hint I'll
stay
oh by the way is it me or does that
giant circular door looking vaguely
inside the Queen that are evil Lackey
cuscuz why and how they see that
suddenly lost control of the talisman
Oh God Majesty what you want the world
title today we took another piece of
under the city of Tartu there will be no
world there will be no world there will
be no world uh there will be no world I
just got it so our heroes are sneaking
around trying to find a way in when
suddenly yeah oh hey someone just
slipped down the trap door from the
outside and into the dining room why do
we install that again so our heroes
fight off the soldiers as we see our
young prince Duke it out with Gestapo
look out he's gonna be crushed by the
luigi logo so Sonia finally reaches the
Queen as Katrin what the hell is that
so the prince and sonia meet up with the
Queen as Sonia tells the prince to run
for cover Prince get katadyn Falcon ah
huh there's a way behind the phone oh
wait don't do that make him come back I
don't want to actually have to chase him
you sahabat my parents like cattle my
brother my sister my uncle my grandpa my
goldfish my chia pet fuck god damn chia
pet but it turns out the Queen has magic
on her side ha ha I slipped the editor
an extra 50 now I can junk out wherever
I want ok seriously knock it off it's
not a good effect
Jesus woman teleports more than Ganon
from The Legend of Zelda
but it turns out the wizard is also
getting his drinks oh she's fun of me I
guess I should stab her again I guess I
should stab her again I guess I should
stab her again
I get such your step okay good things
more on you guys short-term memory loss
now I'll never lead the grand march
so they enter into the candle room where
they had their big final battle huh how
strangely anticlimactic come on remember
me is a horrible blues way to pay and
take your job breaker with you so our
heroes have to escape the fortress
before it all comes crumbling down
through damn my large heaving breasts I
especially love this scene where Arnold
holds up the falling rubble so that they
could pass but look after it fall
you can hopscotch over that
quick run away from nothing so the Queen
is destroyed the Prince is still Brad
and our two actors can't act and they
all live happily ever after
so let's just feel really as bad as some
people make it out to be
reportedly on a Schwarzenegger used to
joke that he would torture people by
showing this movie over and over and
over so it's a really bad bad well it's
definitely bad that's certainly not the
worst in my opinion oh this certainly
made much worse films so I don't really
get why this one so special but I can't
lie it is definitely a bad movie and
when your actor is playing the main
character who looks like this is married
to someone who looks like this yeah
you're gonna be in deep fucking trouble
I'm in this dogger Critic I remember it
so you don't have to